hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
we're in the fight of our lives and
we're losing the
heck we are on a highway to climate hell
with our foot still on the accelerator
it's most at risk from climate change
including low-lying Islands whose very
existence is threatened by rising sea
levels
after all the fuss over whether he'd
attend where she sunak is due to address
the conference within the next hour but
Boris Johnson has already made his
return to the international stage I'm
the spirit of Glasgow that's what I'm
doing yet I'm the spirit of Glasgow uh
cop26
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now for the next 12 days the eyes
of the world are on charmel Shake where
the heads of state environmentalists and
Business Leaders all together in an
attempt to build on the progress made at
previous cop Summits but as cop 27 got
underway at the Egyptian Red Sea Resort
delicates were warned by the UN
Secretary General that the world was
losing the battle against climate change
and that we were instead on a highway to
climate hell with our foot on the
accelerator in his opening statement
Antonio Gutierrez also highlighted one
of the big issues of this year's Summit
loss and damage that means big polluting
Nations compensating smaller countries
at the sharp end of climate change
something General described as a moral
imperative take a look
the contributed list to The Climate
crisis are reaping the Whirlwind sown by
others
and many are blindsided by impacts for
which they had no warning or means of
preparation
this is why I'm calling for a universal
early warning system coverage within
five years
and it is why I am asking that all
governments tax the wind for profits the
fossil fuel companies
let's redirect that money to people
struggling with Rising food and energy
prices and to countries suffering loss
and damage caused by the climate crisis
on addressing loss and damage the scope
must agree on a clear time-bound roadmap
reflective of the scale and urgency of
the challenge
and this roadmap must deliver effective
institutional arrangements for financing
getting concrete results on loss and
damage is a litmus test of the
commitment of the governments to the
success of cop 27.
well one of the stars of last year's cop
26 was MIA Motley the Prime Minister of
Barbados who warned in Glasgow that two
degrees of global warming and
constituted death sentence for Millions
well today she echoed Antonio
gutierrez's call for a windfall tax on
the energy companies which are making
billions of pounds of profits
for loss of damage to work
we believe that it can't only be an
issue of asking State parties to do the
right thing although they must
but we believe that the non-state actors
and the stakeholders the oil and gas
companies and those who facilitate them
need to be brought into a special
convocation between now and cop 28.
how do companies make 200 billion
dollars in profits in the last three
months
and not expect to contribute at least 10
cents in every dollar of profit to a
loss and damage fund
this is what our people expect
when I ask us as we reflect on what a
loss and damage fund can look like and
who should access it that we convene a
special convocation that doesn't only
involve State parties but non-state
actors such as the same companies
well our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter joins
us live now from the conference Hannah
welcome so first of all huge emphasis
this year on loss and damage to the
planet
it is the issue that provides this
Summit with a theme it's also the issue
that provides this Summit with a deep
fault line because developing nations
who have done the very least to cause
the climate crisis are asking wealthy
Nations who have driven the climate
crisis to compensate them for the
damages caused now for the first time
ever loss and damage is actually on the
agenda at a cop
that has been welcomed by developing
nations but they are deeply skeptical
that it will go further than that
despite the U.N secretary General's call
for a new climate solidarity pact and
mere motley's call there for a brand new
reparations fund it's very unlikely from
all the discussions I've been having
with climate diplomats behind the scenes
particularly with negotiators from Big
wealthy Nations that will be anything
more at this Summit than simply an
agreement to keep talking did you feel
being there there was much optimism at
the start of the week
is
[Music]
no I think that climate change has
slipped down the agenda for many
countries because they've been focused
on other issues potentially even
distracted in the words of alok Sharma
and John Kerry the U.N Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez is known for using
strong language their language is
getting more and more robust as he goes
through his tenure as cheap as the U of
the UN and I think this was his
strongest language yet that we are on a
highway to climate hell he's reading at
this point trying to frighten Nations
into doing something on the political
front trying to regain some lost
momentum frankly to ensure that
particularly the bigger emitters the G20
economies do more to bring down their
emissions faster but also to ensure that
those wealthy Nations start to feel
guilt in essence and to match that sense
of guilt and responsibility and moral
obligation with cash
well after all the twoing and throwing
about whether he'd go to charm Rishi
sunak is due to address the conference
well within the next hour now of course
this is about the the future and the
planet that we leave our children but
it's also about the here and now at home
many people are grappling with very
as a result of Russia's illegal War so
that just highlights the need to move
quickly to improve our energy security
to transition to cheaper safer cleaner
forms of energy we remain committed to
the 11.6 billion that we announced and
the last year for international climate
finance and actually today you know
we're seeing the benefit that that can
bring to countries around the world as
we help countries like Kenya for example
transition to Net Zero that actually is
also bringing exciting opportunities for
British companies it's involving the
private sector which is the right thing
to do but also helping those countries
transition to a cleaner future
okay let's go back to Hannah and Trump
so that was Rishi Sun at the very latest
from him he'll speak live within the
next hour do you get a sense um Hannah
that Rishi sunak after that U-turn can
achieve some of the pledges that he
wants to do
Buddhism about presence here I
that's mainly actually because of
um the the problems with the UK's
position on extraction of fossil fuels
we should see now kids now handing out
new licenses in the North Sea and
considering opening a new Coal Mine in
Cumbria and of course Kenya will welcome
that partnership but Kenya is a pelluto
on a tiny tiny scale what really matters
is what happens with the big emitters
with the most powerful economies and the
other thing that's undermining we should
see next position here at cop is that
Boris Johnson has turned up and given
his own speech at a different event
I'm the spirit of Glasgow that's what
I'm doing yeah I'm the spirit of Glasgow
uh cop 26 and it's incredible to think
how much has changed since that last cop
and to be frank how much damage has been
done in just one year to our great
common purpose of tackling man-made
climate change
a lament there really from Boris Johnson
and also a handy opportunity to capture
some of the spotlight let's not
underestimate too much the power of the
United Kingdom remember we were hosts of
cop26 there is still some charity
towards the United Kingdom it hasn't all
been squandered by Rishi sunax you turn
certainly John Kerry the U.S climate
Envoy and others welcoming weishi sunak
here we've seen president Emmanuel
macron of France giving him a a kind of
Joyful welcome in their bilateral
meeting so this is this is Rishi sunak's
first trip abroad as a prime minister
there's a lot on his plate there's a lot
of damage to make up for but he is also
taking tentative steps towards regaining
some of that credibility especially when
it comes to climate change
okay Hannah thank you very much that's
Hannah Thomas Peter there charmele shake
at the cop27 climate conference now
there was a bit of a mystery this
morning when despite Downing streak and
Buckingham palace's insistence that he
wouldn't attend cop 27. King Charles was
still listed as taking part in the
opening ceremony so the un's live feed
said the ceremony would include
interventions from the Egyptian
president the UN Secretary General King
Charles and the leader of the United
Arab Emirates the other three all spoke
in person but there was no appearance
virtual or otherwise from Charles
Buckingham Palace still insists there
are no plans for the king to address cop
27 by video or any other means and just
before we go a reminder that our weekly
climate Show with Tom heat while it's
back and you can watch it on Saturday
and Sunday at 3 30 in the afternoon and
again 7 30 in the evening
well that's all for today but join us
tomorrow at the same time for the very
latest from cop 27.
[Music]